Dark Phoenix continues along x-men
franchise tradition by bringing in
heroes and villains familiar to the
comics fans as well as referencing
classic stories it's easy to miss em all
so here's a look at some of the Dark
Phoenix characters who are more
important than you realized if you
haven't seen the movie here's your
warning that spoilers are head the x-men
through an outdoor party after they save
the endangered astronauts early in the
dark Phoenix where a young woman with
blond hair and striking blue eye
markings sings as clouds of sparkling
lights been in the air around and above
her choreographed by an unseen source
the singer is Alison Blair codename
Dazzler a mutant who can transform sound
into light as a member of the x-men she
uses her powers to blind enemies or to
attack with bolts of hard light it's
fitting Dark Phoenix of the film that
introduces her given that the x-men
attempt to recruit her in the 1980's
uncanny x-men number 130 just 5 issues
before the Dark Phoenix story officially
kicked off initially named the disco
Queen Dazzler would appear in Marvel
Comics and then Casablanca Records would
find a singer who would take on the
persona of a hero and produce an actual
record a lot of things went wrong though
and Dazzler went from being an
interesting media experiment to a
d-lister Molson periphery of Marvel's
narrative after gene kills mystique the
troubled hero travels to a remote island
though it's never named it seems to be a
version of Genosha a place that we learn
was given to Magneto and other mutants
as a homeland look I know who you are I
don't wanna fight not you don't in the
comics Genosha begins as an island
nation ruled by humans for mutants are
enslaved by the government and their
abilities are used to serve the state in
the 1990 event extinction agenda the
x-men x-factor and the new mutants
joined forces and topple Genosha scre
upped government in 1999 x-men number 87
the United Nations gives the country to
magneto as a mutant homeland
under his leadership it grows into
something much larger than we see in the
Dark Phoenix one of the Dark Phoenix is
more mysterious minor characters is a
rekey one of the Genosha pnes magneto
brings with him when he attempts to kill
Jean Grey his powers revolve around his
long hair which he uses to
grapple or strike opponents while he's
initially an enemy of the x-men he's
arrested with the heroes and fights
alongside them in their battle against
the d'bari on the train Parikh II
doesn't appear in the comics it was
initially reported Andrew Stellan would
be playing a different character IGN
reported that Stalin's character was Red
Lotus in Australian Chinese character
from Xtreme x-men whose powers have
nothing to do with hair manipulation not
that any of that matters all that much
Ricci essentially disappears from the
movie during the train battle when
Professor X makes a speech after
receiving an award from the president
one of the white house guests is Chris
Claremont a writer whose work on the
x-men comics helped make them the
household names they are now he started
writing x-men in 1975 and wrote them
continuously until 1991 he returns to
the franchise occasionally even now he
wrote the first Wolverine miniseries
with artist Frank Miller and when Logan
finally got his own ongoing series
Claremont was its first scribe Claremont
established a foundation for much of
what we see in the films it was
Claremont who introduced the idea that
magneto is a Holocaust survivor and that
his actions stem from his horrific
experiences during that time and of
course it was Claremont and collaborator
John Byrne who crafted the Dark Phoenix
saga we had no expectations at all when
we did the story we just want to do a
really great story there's a lot of
mystery surrounding Jessica Chastain's
character leading up to the release of
Dark Phoenix we now know she plays Buch
a member of the nearly extinct
extraterrestrial race the d'bari she
siphoned some of the Phoenix power from
Jean Grey but eventually is destroyed
before Jean takes to the stars
Luke is one of Marvel's oldest super
villains though in the comics she is a
he in his first appearance way back in
1964 Avengers number four Luke turns the
Avengers to stone and order of Namor the
Submariner who promises to retrieve
books crash spaceship in return little
was hurt from the character until
Phoenix destroyed his homeworld in 1980s
uncanny x-men number 135 he's since made
sporadic appearances using the name star
hammer and is usually intent on getting
revenge on Phoenix Nightcrawler is
clearly not ready for what he
experiences in Dark Phoenix he suffers
terrible guilt when he's forced to leave
Jean behind in the space shuttle
Gina very chic
once gene goes bad the blue elf is
helpless against her Phoenix beats him
up a couple of times and she doesn't
pull her punches in the battle against
Magneto and his followers in New York
City Nightcrawler is stressed to his
limits as the rest of the team calls on
him for aid when a guard was trying to
help him is killed by one of the d'bari
and the prison transport train he
finally snaps and we see an
uncharacteristic viciousness he uses
more brutal tactics than we've ever seen
from him ultimately teleporting one of
the d'bari to the train tracks giving
her an evil grin and teleporting away
before the approaching train kills his
enemy he's not quite the violent
alternate universe version of Kirk from
the comics but he's got that vibe we
don't see or hear much from Selene in
the Dark Phoenix we know she's good with
knives and has psychic powers strong
enough to at least hold Professor X at
bay and in spite of her earlier mission
of killing Jean Grey she sacrifices
herself fighting the d'bari Selene from
the source material is much more complex
she was once known as the black queen of
the Hellfire Club and one of the world's
most powerful mutants in part because of
her wide range of powers she can suck
the life force out of others to make
herself stronger and along with the
telepathic power she shows in dark
Phoenix
she's also telekinetic she's also very
tough to kill no one knows how long
she's been alive only that it's been for
a millennia more than any other x-men
film Dark Phoenix reveals the shameful
manipulations of the seemingly
benevolent Professor X not only did
Xavier lie to Jean when he told her that
her father was dead but without anyone
else's knowledge he placed psychic
blocks in her mind to protect her from
traumatic memories the Phoenix force
tears those blocks down once it inhabits
Jean you think you can fix me Jean you
are not broken
Xavier being a manipulative jerk is
nothing new to the comic fans over the
years characters who were once almost
fanatically loyal to Xavier begin to
lose trust in their mentor one of the
most infamous examples of Professor X
dishonesty comes during Joss Whedon's
run on astonishing x-men when the
x-men's technological miraculous Danger
Room comes alive and it temps to kill
the team
to light that Professor X knew the
danger room had a mind of its own ever
since it went online but kept it's life
is secret so no one would object to use
it to train total jerk move professor
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit that bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]